[Music]
[Applause]
he's michael buble singer-songwriter
record producer a 10th anniversary
deluxe edition of michael buble's
classic album christmas is available now
great to have you back on the program
michael i'm curious what it's like when
you go you and your wife go to a
christmas party and somebody's got a
piano there
what
happens it's it's just it's forget about
the christmas party what about the
shopping mall
or the elevator
oh or the
funeral home
when wait when you hear your music
yeah that's a scary place you don't want
to hear the elevator that's for sure
but uh definitely i mean every i just
went and bought stuff for my wife for
christmas you know of course the last
minute
shopper just panicking you know what do
i get and of course you know people see
me and say like can you sing that one
did you like jingle bells
but my with my personality though you
know i'm in the middle of bed bath and
beyond going jingle bells jingle bells
jingle all the way
kevin bacon said that he hates going to
a reception a wedding reception because
everybody thinks he's going to dance
like he did in footloose
like come on hey come on kevin dance
like you did in footloose there yeah
if i could dance like kevin i probably
would i probably would be dancing yeah
but if he could sing like you then he
would be singing
yeah probably yeah where's the strangest
place though you've been asked like you
know to sing a song
uh you know weirdly i think it was my
grandma's funeral and i was really
emotional i was devastated you know i
was just i was a big day for all of us
and this uh sweet woman that we had
hired in catering this nice italian lady
came up to me as i exited the bathroom
you know and uh
she said sing a song
sing home
and you know again in my personality i
say like i don't know what this is
what is the what is the one song
that somebody else sings
that you wish was yours
oh god it's a great question man there's
so many i think
i mean i think god only knows uh
the
is one of the i mean it's one of the
most beautiful songs ever written so the
beach boys i wish it was mine i wish
half the ed sheeran songs that he wrote
were mine
sometimes i fantasize about just you
know going back in time and just
stealing them you know
but do you do you do covers
you have
i mean you're a very humble guy you know
a lot of artists don't want to do covers
of somebody else but
you have no problem with no i do you
know what's weird i i live in a very
weird you know what man it's weird i
lived in a very strange place as an
artist because i
i am
i cover songs i mean i do what say
sinatra did or presley you know i take
these songs and i reinterpret them
the great american songbook but my
biggest
successes have been songs that i've
written
have been the pop songs which is very
weird for people to try to put me in a
box because why what am i because those
guys dean or
frank or
tony bennett they didn't write songs
they didn't have pop songs on the radio
so why do you you know what i mean it's
very strange to have to explain
especially if people don't know they
don't understand the same guy who wrote
haven't met you yet or everything or
home
is the same guy who's doing feeling good
or
uh come fly with me
who's tougher to cover though if you
look at those guys that you met like is
sinatra tough to cover
it's never the artist it's more about
the song and the history of the song and
who's
had a part in the history of the song
you know that's it's funny i find it i
don't find it easy to write songs it's
challenging to write a good so obviously
everybody could do it if they could but
when i write a song it's original and no
one can compare it to anything
when i cover
come fly with me
you're now dealing with a song that's
been tackled by ella fitzgerald frank
sinatra you know conic there's this all
these all of these so it's
you know what's weird i think that's
what i'm i'm best at i think if anything
forget about singing
or that part of reinterpreting it as a
as a
vocalist
i think what i'm best at is
conceptualizing and coming up with
um
ideas to make a song fresh and sort of
almost very cinematic ideas within the
arrangement like say something like
crimey river i don't know if you ever
heard my my version of siame river but
crimea river is a great song
but it took i was you know i think i was
in a having a bath or something and i
had come up with this line
and this big dramatic build and when i
took it to the producer i sang it to him
he right away he understood the concept
and like i said it was very cinematic it
was almost like a james bond-esque
build and you could feel the drama and i
knew for my show it would be a great way
to open the show and
so that is the challenge
taking something that's been done so
many times and making it sound brand new
and you know you've done it when you
take a song and it's a standard that's
been there for 60 years or 80 years and
people say i love you know
i love that you wrote this or whatever
they you know they'll tell me they'll
say like i love traffic like feeling
good you know they'll say like wow i
love the way you know you wrote feeling
good it's amazing and of course i'll say
thank you
but as opposed to i didn't write that
you have to ask for permission
to cover of some song
no you don't you don't have to ask and
what's weirder is like so it's happened
to me so years ago i wrote a song called
home
and it was good for me it went number
one on on this format a radio on hd or
whatever
and then blake shelton the country
singer he covered it
and he had a number one that was bigger
than my number one and he had his number
one was in country radio
across the pond a band called westlife
had a number one with it they called the
record home
and so people kept coming up to me and
saying i love that cover of west life
where i love that place
and the same thing was happening i was
like no i wrote that that's mine but
what do you get paid off of that
a ton
good for you done good
thank you
keep listening to blake shelton's home
everyone
what are those checks like though when
they come in that is there a reference
to
where the money's coming from
yes there definitely is it's all broken
out it's weird now because of the way
that streaming is i mean isn't your is
your world changed with streaming
how much is your world changing
how things are remunerating podcast
uh digital like we had 11.9
million downloads last month
wow that's a lot
that's a lot yeah and you know and do
you know what you're you're kind of that
this is a terrible conversation to have
but do you know what the cut is like i
have no idea i think i know my manager
deal uh he's a great guy's name is bruce
allen
i know he's very and he's generous i get
i get 20 he gets baby
uh
i think that's a good deal i've been
told he told me it's a very good deal
wow you know what you're kind of dead
you know what you like do you know what
you get out of that it it's so
the pie is cut up in so many slices
that
that you you know where things go and
what they go for
and and i bought my own man cave and
then i have to rent out the equipment
so
you know i'm i'm i'm still paying people
for things that they're not involved
with the show anymore
if that makes sense
okay well i hope and i i know my glove
is leaving i hope you get to still pay
him um even when he's gone can you
i know this is you know i'm i'm asking
you to do something for me you know
you're in the elevator you're at a
funeral
do you got something to sing to mclovin
that
like you know this is the we got
20 more minutes
you guys got something we can just kind
of give him because we didn't get him
anything good today
i mean we're not that sorry he's going
but we like we'd like to convey that if
we could
absolutely i got something lightly
emotional that you could sing to mclovin
okay let me just try uh like uh okay
hold on let me go what about this nick
okay wait hold on michael
i gotta give the official introduction
here
the 10th anniversary deluxe edition and
michael's not telling me to say this i'm
doing this his uh classic album
christmas available now a new studio
album coming out next spring by
invitation he also has uh a fragrance
for women on set what
i don't know anymore i it's not even me
it's the manager
it smells like the manager do you get 20
of that as well
wait yes of course i do
okay here we go michael buble sings to
mclovin
mclovin fangs
[Music]
the memories
you weren't good but you were okay
we thought you were fine
maybe you were adequate
i think it is time to say
thanks for
the memories
thank you
[Applause]
i was trying to think of what rhymes
with adequate
uh by the way i didn't prep michael to
do that he but but he does know your
limitations mclovin was that like bette
midler singing to johnny carson was that
the same thing kind of that kind of was
that accepted i don't think that was as
hungover as i am right now
have you ever played a show
drunk
never that's weird people think often
there's a big thing when i started
because i was i was so i was so loose
you know i was here's the thing i did
this
i started when i was 16
and my grandpa used to sneak me into
nightclubs and he was a plumber and so
the only way that we knew how to get me
out there was he would
trade so he'd get musicians or a club
guy and he'd say to the club guy let my
grandson into sing and they'd say no my
your gran your kid he's 6 16 years old
they were drinking ages 19. he'd say
listen i'll go and i'll fix the toilets
and i'll put in a hot water heater in
the kitchen here and he would go in and
and trade contra and they'd let me up on
stage so i did this from like it's been
a long you know even weirder
i i think this is true but
i was 16 in vancouver playing on like u
street on these little clubs and bars
and restaurants and stuff and across the
street was a kid even younger than me
that was doing stand up at like 14 and
15 and that was seth rogen and i used to
hear about him i used to hear about like
oh you know there's this kid there's
this young kid like you and he's doing
this you know
he's in the clubs the adult clubs and
stuff anyway so by the time i got to
doing this at 26 and finally got signed
it had been 10 years of me working so i
was very loose up there very you know
confident and it was very easy but fun
for me but people say well he's wasted
that guy's wasted but dean martin always
gave you the impression that he was
wasted
but he wasn't but i think that's the
impression i gave but the truth is
i'm such a control freak
that i would never ever do anything that
could i would ever lose that kind of
control i i
like i think that um
it's funny i just did this christmas
special and lauren michaels was the
producer we were talking about a lot of
the artists because i did a thing with
jimmy fallon
we were talking about and you know a lot
of those guys
and we were actually talking about how
loose they all seem and how great they
are at improvisation
but they're most of them 95 percent of
them
are so structured
and they're so um
you know what i mean you're
that it all seems like it's just
off the cuff easy but that's because
that's that's i was gonna swear that
they have prepared
so well like jimmy fallon it's funny you
know sweet and funny and you know real
silly and goofy and stuff when you but
man backstage when we were working out
this gag that we were doing it wasn't it
was real serious real structured and uh
so no never been drunk never been high
um
but that but when we switch over to
to my normal life
i've never been sober
it's off stage where the problems are
well done uh
your football your fantasy football team
in shambles
yep
yeah
yeah tom brady and elmo kamara were my
i'd look at like that i actually this
isn't a joke i just put my head down
he's shamed
[Laughter]
um
yeah you feel pretty good tom brady i
had aaron rodgers and tom brady and i
put in tom and i really liked brady and
obviously he's a great player that's
just four points and um kamara just was
invisible
are you a seahawks fan
i am a seahawks oh sorry about that too
sorry about that michael it's really
getting it's just getting much worse
more more drinking uh before i let you
go um yeah
i play judge here and i want you to be
honest
okay this is american idol i want you to
can this person sing okay okay here we
go
in the meadow we can build a snowman
we'll pretend that he is parson brown
he'll say i am married we'll say no man
but you can do the job when you're in
town
yeah
yeah actually yeah would you send him on
to hollywood if you're simon cowell
i would go you know the first thing i
would do i'd say hey randy newman hey
we're going to do a new disney track you
don't even have to sing it we have a guy
who can sound like you really
i think so he's kind of got that thing
who was that that's fritzy
that's really good that was really nice
you got that kind of that randy
newmaness that cool that kind of
character to his voice
do you know randy newman todd now i do
wait where come on he's done all these
great soundtracks
is anyone that sounds like short people
and stuff like that yeah you've got a
friend and yeah you got a friend in me
[Applause]
hey do you want to hear frizzy do rick
ashley
here we go we're no strangers to
you know the rules and so do i never
gonna give never gonna give never gonna
give me jump in michael never gonna let
him
run around
[Music]
i would love to get in the shower with
me
we would sound so good together that can
be arranged michael that is a fabulous
idea
it'll have to be a big shower though to
get todd in there with you all right
really
uh
great to talk to you again and uh
likewise man
and i'm so excited to be here on this
day like the last day of christmas it's
like school you know yeah remember the
last day of school when you were going
off for christmas break and it was so
exciting yeah now my football's dead i
got my vancouver giant hockey team that
i'll be watching
well that's how i'm spending a break
thank you michael great to talk to you
merry christmas thank you and your
family thank you buddy god bless guys
take care that's michael buble singer
songwriter record producer what a cool
guy dude is awesome he plays he wants to
entertain and it makes my job so much
easier when you have somebody who's
willing to play like that